you know Jay Inspector General Michael
Horowitz facing off with lawmakers again
today over his report on the Clinton
email investigation
Republican lawmakers pressing the
Horowitz / revelations of FBI bias they
prejudge the outcome of the Hillary
Clinton investigation before the
investigation ended and these exact same
FBI agents and attorneys prejudge the
outcome of the Russia investigation
before it even began do you believe this
text shows political bias I think as we
found it clearly shows a bias state of
mind
February March 2 2016 Peter struck said
Trump's abysmal Trump's an idiot he's a
bleep an idiot Hillary should win a
hundred million to zero sounds to me
like he hates the president his text
messages would certainly leave that as
the implication Horowitz confirming to
Congress he's investigating whether
embattled FBI official Peter Strock
anti-trump bias factored into the launch
of the bureau's Russia probe stocks
lawyer is also firing back against
criticism saying his client is not a
conspirator but instead ready a patriot
all right Kimberly we're just getting
word from Struck's law apparently he's
been escorted out of the FBI office
building yeah well I hope after
listening to trey Gowdy today that he
like speed-dialed the best like
washington DC defense lawyer and I mean
that seriously because if you listen to
me Trey earlier today it was quite
compelling and persuasive he was quite
insistent and really fired up about the
whole thing and I you know when I was
listening to him it's like wow he's
really kind of like made the case
against not only struck but call me you
know and McCabe and Paige and it's just
it's bad I mean it's really bad for the
United States bad for the FBI the system
of justice and you know trey Gowdy kept
making the point like there can be no
fairness in the process with this level
of inherent bias very very biased and
we're now learning that there were more
FBI agents who were sending anti-trump
texts and one maybe two of those lawyers
wound up in the Muller team Dana I mean
the smaller team is just packed full of
these people at this point and they were
removed for aunt
try boss by Muller only uh three or four
months ago though yeah I know I have to
can I tell you something I didn't follow
that particular piece of it because I
was following immigration all day I did
note that today catherine herridge said
that Peter Straub could actually
willingly testify in front of Congress
by the end of the week that'll mean so
yeah I'm looking I will pay attention to
that okay I think we all will Greg what
do you think about the AG hearing well
first of all I believe that strux texts
are more incriminating in terms of
conspiracies than anything in the
russian collusion thing I was trying to
think about this you know what is the
quote would be comparable to writing
stop Trump would be trump
texting call Putin we've got to stop
Hillary now we got what our day that
would be the smoke again but the big
story to me is always going to betray
car Trey Gowdy's ever changing hair he's
like this he's like he's like Martin
Landau in Mission Impossible he has a
suitcase full of sideburns and goatees
like he's in the Americans it's like
he's got to go someone he is a Russian
agent yeah trey gowdy
that is not how he looks a CIA or
something no I think he works for the
Russians he's a national man of mystery
and by the way I think the beard is very
becoming although his politics some time
is not so becoming look yeah I actually
did watch it it's better than watching
soap opera in the middle of the day and
the reason why I watched it it's because
underneath all of the partisan rhetoric
about the IG report we learned that once
again we have an agency that has some
dysfunction and whether you focus on
those emails texts mm-hmm disgusted I'm
a former federal employee disgusting
let's just say disgust disgust it's
disgusting whether it's saying those
things about mr. Trump or saying those
things about miss miss Clinton they are
not hard to text each other about their
personal dislike of a particular
candidate blah blah blah that being said
the Office of Professional
Responsibility must now do their job and
remove those who are still in the
employment of the federal government
beyond that I think this report tells us
a lot about mr. Comey state of mind the
fact that he was insubordinate the fact
that he believed that he alone could
deliver the so-called message to the
American people
didn't have to check with his boss so
there's a lot to learn in his I haven't
read all of it because as you know there
are no pictures I read faster when I see
pictures but it it is a it is a story
that we need to know and by the way you
know you and I can have a conversation
about the Russians and I can speak a
little bit of the language now because I
do believe that we need to get to the
bottom of what happen until I'm married
to a Russian so I can speak a little
and speaking of coaming handling of the
classified memos is under investigation
so everyone's under investigation at
this point you will be soon oh we got
another kumbaya in the disegno
can we breathe out the eyes and complete
this can we agree though that these
these copies things they're like stalker
it's like zero zero at half time look
when you're watching these things it's
like it's like I think this was a slam
dunk by the but then the next one will
be
wait a minute 38 and the guy explores
and you're like thank you I like soccer
will you cheer a pass yeah well I think
trey gowdy scored today yeah well with
that because of his goatee all right